si el viaje puede hacerse en tren en
menos de dos horas y media el vuelo
comercial queda descartado
Christopher ministro adjunto de
transición ecológica tuiteó que se
trataba de un paso más hacia la
descarbonización de nuestros transportes
pero los críticos lo califican en el
mejor de los casos de gestos simbólico
en el peor de un escandaloso caso de
ecoimpostura las líneas afectadas Serán
las conexiones París París y París
burdeos desde el Aeropuerto parisino de
orley líneas que no circulan desde el
cómic 19 y para que se aplique la
prohibición tiene que ser posible tomar
el tren de ida y vuelta en el mismo día
dejando ocho horas intermedias en la
ciudad de destino creando una laguna
para los vuelos
otro aeropuerto de la gran región
Parisina la prohibición tampoco se
aplica a los vuelos de conexión la ley
sobre el clima y resiliencia se votó en
2021 pero esta cláusula fue impugnada
por el sector aéreo lo que retrasó su
implementación la ley en Sí fue fruto de
una iniciativa de democracia
participativa 150 personas elegidas al
azar para redactar una hoja de ruta para
el futuro verde de Francia hicieron 149
propuestas la mayoría de las cuales se
diluyeron Cuando el proyecto de ley
llegó al parlamento la propuesta en
cuestión pretendía originalmente
suprimir los vuelos en los que la
alternativa ferroviaria era de hasta 4
horas y no de dos horas y media